talk about education and after months of
distance learning the clark county
school district now has a plan to get
students back into the classroom
it's a hybrid model it combines learning
at home and in person
hector mejia is live at district
headquarters with the details good
morning hector hey there alex good
morning and right now it's just a
proposal the school board of trustees
here at ccsd will consider the plan this
week and potentially vote on it
as early as this thursday during a
scheduled meeting and the plan
is quite long it has 205 pages
if it passes employees would return back
to work
as soon as december 1st it proposes
smaller classes
half the size january 4th is when
students in certain grades would start
their new
hybrid schedule that's for kids in pre-k
to second grade
those in sixth grade and 11th to 12th
grades
all other grades would start on january
11th again if it gets approved
and students would be divided in
different learning groups for either
hybrid or full-time remote learning
however not everyone is on board we
talked with parents and teachers who
seem to have
different opinions nothing really beats
face-to-face learning and being in the
same room as the person you're learning
from
as a kindergarten teacher i am not uh
comfortable with that
just because i know especially when
we're talking about primary there's no
way that they're going to be able to
adhere
to the social distance and guidelines
mask wearing and extra cleaning measures
will be in place in the schools and the
proposal
also provides visuals on how to space
out desks
we've also learned no playground
equipment water fountains or even field
trips would be allowed when school
begins next year
and again the board will consider this
plan this thursday and they could vote
on it
on that same night reporting live on a
very chilly tuesday morning hector mejia
alex back to you all right thanks hector
stay warm out there
we should also tell you the largest
teachers you